あちょっと風邪気味です最近の動画はめちゃくちゃなことが多いから今日はちょっと
伸びていきます
ブーブーんっ
分わー
popular を
いやー
元気ドライブドラゴンゲーム&ファーストフェネックしょん君たちはミニ四駆やって
ことは2回目に送ってね
車玩具があって実際に作ってすごいスピード走るおもちゃなんですけどなんか音色ね再
ブームが来てるみたいでオカマ役遊戯王カード手にねそういうお店に行くんですけど
結構ミニ四駆やってる人が多くてちょっと big
にしてますそれの現代版みたいな感じかなちょっとよくわかんないんですけども買って
しまいました
これ僕の好きなタイプですドラゴンで士郎登っているはこう清潔感があっていいんです
よねドラゴンゲイルとこの2つを買ってみましたがまぁ今の子どもたちにとっている
ミニョンかこれなのかも
僕にそのなんかそういうホビーケアすごい好きでクラッシュギアをやってたして0
ベイトもやってた b だもん
ってた結構にそういうおもちゃめかしてずっとやっててビッグドライブをすごい楽し
そうなるってもっとで買ってみましたとりあえずことドラゴンゲートバージョン
affection をつくってみましょう
うんっよかったこれでなかったその日に s すごいよめっちゃ硬いのにアースを
ぶつけてみましょう
オーケンん
ん
ana
んおお
もうなんかシンプルセディックドライブんすっきりシンプルです
は速させず僕ちゃんの激ドライブ
度でもゲイ年度大丸バウンスとフェネックシーンを作ってあげましょう
判例で無事ライバルも完成しましたこれが僕の橋そしてこれが開いてんじゃねーよ走ら
せてんだもう全然ブーブーで面白くないんでなんとなーーーとですねこの子の泥鬼女
ライブ用のベイシング上買ってきました
こちらあー女ぜよねちょっとねちょっと何を考えたら高まっちゃうんでさぁこちら力
ドライブ用のレース場マツダスピードがいいでございます
よかったなお前らこれでいつでも走れるんだぞ
のめんどくさっほー
安全帯めんどくてあぁ今朝の4時なんだよねー
よろしくねー
おわー
はいひとまずて味完成しましたーー
俺だ back back 名前忘れた
で g drive この劇ドライブ gt 通い始めますさあ果たして
小付空へばメディアおくとそれだけ違う動きをみせるぞとまずいって俺とこいつね走ら
せてみよう
要素破線で埋めます
ああああああ
rar
car
80雨逆走しちゃうわけ
キャッツクレイドルでってなんぼのところは単位までわかったでしょうか
めちゃくちゃ速いバックライダー次は全然ないですができ誰全然早いです次は実際に
この偉大でちょっと食べて飲んでみましょう
どんな感じになるのか全然想像つかれますじゃあ
ばかりしゃべって
皆様 see
ああああああ
voodoo
ban
ます
形にしてい
月でない